joining us now with reaction we have the
host the michelle malkin investigates
see our TV michelle malkin former White
House press secretary Sean Spicer you
know it was 2009 Michelle when they're
right you know many are signing a
petition for Roman Polanski you saw the
roar and the standing ovation I think
what Oprah said is right I think she's
dead on I have faith in her I don't have
faith in all these people racing for the
next Savior well as in the clip that you
just showed among the people who left to
their feet for Roman Polanski were
hypocrite Meryl Streep and of course now
accused multiple predator Harvey
Weinstein and I have to disagree with
you slightly Sean because as much as
I've heard the way we've been family for
years you go right ahead yeah so I do
not join in all of the effusive praise
for Oprah's speech last night I thought
it was textbook partisan and ideological
identity liberalism and she herself is
one who has been accused by multiple
victims of Harvey Weinstein of being a
fixer for Harvey Weinstein there are
many infamous pictures of her suing the
pictures off of but the but thankfully
you have to be fair she did she know we
don't know if she knew well a lot of
people taking pictures with me and you
over the years we don't know them no
question about it but the consensus from
so many of the people who have been
complaining about Harvey Weinstein for
years and been ignored is that quote
unquote
everybody knew Meryl Streep knew and
many people believed that Oprah Winfrey
knew as well so look the idea that
Hollywood and Democrat strategists think
somehow that Oprah Winfrey has a chance
in 2020 and that she's allowing all of
this buzz to happen she has her
boyfriend Stedman cheering on all of the
gossip about a potential run
what would we get we'd get another eight
years of the same kind of Chicago
machine identity liberalism that we got
under Barack Obama who has in part so
large a role of Oprah Winfrey to thank
for getting to him getting him where he
was and and last night all of Hollywood
and Oprah were pretending as if the last
eight years of the Obama administration
didn't happen and that's to me I think
what's most troubling the unreality of
the people in the Hollywood bubble Shan
I guess the difference I go back I've I
felt in many ways between vetting Obama
and Reverend Wright and Black Liberation
Theology in Dorn's and Ayers and acorn
and Olinsky and Frank Marshall Davis I
felt there were a few of us Michelle I
know was one and and there were a few of
us that vetted him and then after eight
years there were very few of us that
talked about what we had 13 million more
Americans on food stamps eight million
more in poverty the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s worst
recovery since the 40s lowest
homeownership rate in 51 years and we
doubled the debt and he gave a ran one
hundred and fifty billion dollars so
truth and facts and substance matters
but I kind of feel I was alone here in a
lot of ways I had Michelle was like
family to me by my side and a few others
that's about it so why the rush for a
savior again when the last savior they
chose failed so miserably
well look I think the thing that's
interesting is that what Oprah said last
night all Americans should agree with
and I agree with you that respecting
women creating a safe work environment
for all individuals is something that we
should all agree on it shouldn't be
beyond politics it should be beyond
ideology it should be something that
every American and every human supports
that being said I think that the
interesting thing last night is she
didn't talk about policy she didn't talk
about know how to solve some of the more
controversial and to your point right
now I mean they're about to coronate
somebody who gave a speech on frankly
something that not only should we all
agree on but something that you aptly
point out is highly hypocrite oh by the
way say people in that room they did
we're I mean Shawn it's not just Roman
Polanski's it's Bill Clinton this others
who wouldn't even an opportunity to
speak out mate they overlooked it they
did more you know you have to sit in a
room I don't know how the hell you did
your job
for as long as you did and I noticed in
an interview with se copy were kind of
hard on yourself and I'm thinking you
know you really didn't do that much role
because they were so hostile I can't
think of a moment they've given Trump a
break and they gave Obama every break Oh
both before during and after what's your
experience with the press center oh it
look I don't a lot of these guys for
sometimes in some cases more than two
decades I think it was unbelievably a
massive hostility never seen before and
the Pew Center backed it up 63% of the
coverage against President Trump was
negative only 5% positive which is three
times what that wasn't Obama I mean they
came out guns a-blazing in the
mainstream media they were they were
upset that they were wrong and they were
gonna take it out on their coverage all
right last word Michelle well I think
that Hollywood and the Democrats need to
put down the Oprah bong and stop
inhaling and I think probably the reason
why they're so desperate is if you look
at the current field of Democrat
potential candidates for 2020 you've got
the pretend Ian Elizabeth Warren you've
got Bernie Sanders will be 79 Maxine
Waters who's cast as the fresh face of
the Democrat Party no wonder they're
grasping for the straw of Oprah Winfrey
all right guys good to see you
appreciate you both being with us